God Called Jesus a spirit of him in the
Quran so it's not it's not it's not the
god that that is communicating in Quran
it's the people who are giving out the
false information out there so so the
religion itself and Prophet Muhammad
itself they never said oh Jesus is not
this or that he is the spirit of God and
that is like 100% truth and no one can
change that Jesus was born as a Miracle
he's the spirit of God he will return
and he is he is the like out of all
prophets out of all prophets why did
Allah chose Jesus to be returned like
this is the question like I a Muslim I'm
a Muslim and I'm never going to say oh
Jesus is just a normal Prophet no he's
something Beyond he's something very
precious in Islam that Allah chose him
over Moses Abraham Isaac Jacob and we
have got so many prophets but Allah
chose Jesus for the return like there's
a thing so if you think about as a
conscious Muslim as a conscious Muslim I
would never disrespect or disr Jesus I I
would never know their knowledge but I'm
never going to like assume that Islam is
bad or Prophet Muhammad was bad as well
because I know the fact that people
create hatred in the name of um religion
in the name of Islam and they were there
were like like people who were not loyal
to Prophet Muhammad I like I like some
things that you said I'm getting out of
breath it's just I'm pregnant sorry
that's all right let me let me give you
a little break but you you said some
very eye openening things that there's a
reason why Jesus is born of a virgin a
reason why Jesus is the one who's going
to come back um that he's the one who's
chosen to do these things there's
something special about him the question
is what is it what is it about Jesus
that he is the one who's born through a
virgin um and is the one who's going to
return and come back right on the day of
judgment and un Al living Antichrist and
stuff like that there's something unique
and special about Jesus who is the only
Prophet who's called the spirit of God
and the word of God what is it about him
now just just mention that he was called
all of that in Quran so all of this is
in the Quran this is all in the Quran
now this is the thing have you have you
ever read the gospel before absolutely
yes because I you know I grew up in
Ireland basically so I I went to a
Catholic School all girls catholic
school in Longford and I used to go we
had like a little catholic are you
Catholic by the way I I'm not Catholic
personally but I know what you yeah so
we had like a little church and I was
always interested and I always felt
peace to be honest I'm I'm not going to
say I felt peace more peace in mosque
than a church I felt like it was all the
same we had we had we follow the same
God basically we F we have absolutely
same morals same beliefs everything it's
just the people that are below spreading
all the hatred doing things for money
and you know it's just disgusting what
they're doing and they're not even loyal
to Prophet Muhammad because they're
spreading false information about him
that he married a 9-year-old or a 6year
old all do false information like it's
contradicted itself like like if if you
say that he came came into this world to
spread the right message why would he
just fool around marrying little kid
little girls and all that you know
that's not true he didn't come to this
world to marry little girls and stuff he
came into this uh world to spread the
word of God to spread but but sister
Bambi that's that that is something that
the sources say he did though you know
those sources let me tell you those
sources are literally sourced by the
people that was against him that didn't
really like him are you are you Sunni or
are you Shia or what what sect of Islam
do you follow oh you do you do know
about Shia and Sydney yeah I'm I'm Shia
by the way and makes sense makes sense
you know something something triggered
my ears when you said that they say the
ones who betrayed the prophet they say
that those people are good I was like
and this is why I love Jesus you know
where I coming I'm coming from this is
why I love Humanity in Jesus because I'm
AIA because I know what Muslims actually
did with the with the family of prophet
itself yeah so this is why you know we
we don't see things as black and white
like just pray to God five times a day
follow Prophet Muhammad and you'll go to
heaven no there's like there's so many
things in this world you know there's so
many things and Jesus can I show you
something with what Jesus said yeah of
course pointing back to his his
uniqueness he says something like this
so this is in the Gospel of John this is
uh verse 35 it says Jesus said to them
it says Jesus said to them I am the
bread of life whoever comes to me shall
not hunger and whoever believes in me
shall never thirst but I said to you
that you have seen me and yet you do not
believe all that the father gives me
will come to me and whoever comes to me
I will never cast out for I have come
down from heaven not to do my own will
but the will of him who sent me and this
is the will of him who sent me that I
should lose nothing of all that he has
given me but raise it up on the last day
for this is the will of my father that
everyone who looks on the son and
believes in Him should have eternal life
and I will raise him up on the last day
exactly so what I understand from this
worse is that he's asking your Salish
okay wait I don't know the he asked yes
he's asking your salvation so he's
basically like Bas he's basically
telling the world you need to do good
stuff and you need to return back to the
god and I will be there you from well he
specifically says he specifically not
not that you do good stuff but even
though that's a good thing yes but
that's not what he's saying he's saying
come to me come to me exactly he says
come to me and I you if you come to me
you will never hunger you will never
thirst because I will give you the food
and the water that never runs out
spiritually he's going to make you
spiritually full complete and you know
why why he said that because that time
he was representing the Father the the
he was representing the god that's why
he said I am here to represent God and I
will like I will save you from all the
bad things that's why because that time
he was representing the whole the
message right so so do you think let me
let me ask you this even as a Muslim do
you think that a a prophet a good Muslim
Prophet could ever say come to me and I
will make sure you hunger and there's no
more or come to me and I'm going to be
the I'm the Son of God who will raise
you up on the last day on on the day of
Resurrection you take a a prophet or
something you if you ask me as a Shia
point of view MH like not as as a like a
Muslim strict Muslim if you ask me as a
Shia Muslim point of view we do have
deities like we do have people like
Jesus in Islam like we we don't take um
Prophet Muhammad as a normal human like
you know how Muslims take that he's he
was a he was a normal human came in like
we don't take Jesus as a normal human we
don't take we don't take Prophet
Muhammad as a normal human and there
there's there's other people in like
Shia Islam that are for salvation like
they are they're they're there to save
you from Hellfire and then basically how
you believe that like certain some of
these figures like Muhammad and others
have some Divinity to them and they can
give you salvation yes exactly and I do
believe Jesus have it as well to be
honest because they came in they came
into this world as a spiritual guide
they're not like us they're not like
humans they were different than us so
they are the source of you know what's
the word I keep forgetting things
salvation salvation Salvation they're
they're basically like they're to
protect us from Hellfire and stuff
they're the figures that we need to
follow and follow their path and stuff
to reach the god you to reach the father
as you say father
wow yeah I I don't have much brother God
logic but I'm happy that she said that
she's Shia and nice to meet you bumbi I
want to correct something uh what you
probably didn't in her and um again I I
have have no hate to you I just want to
mention a source and I will go down yes
here's a sh Source sh SCE sh sh Source
where it says that was a young baby girl
let me quote
it
again volume one page
276 write it down volume one page 276 it
says the wife of Muhammad so talking
about
aaak the prophet married AA in Mecca
when she was seven years old and he
married no virgin except her and then he
continues he consumated the marriage
with with her when she was 9 years old
and this is what a Shia Source yeah so
thank you let me stop you there like
I'll justify this so if it if there's
talking about consummating a marriage we
she asked we don't believe that Prophet
came into like mess about like he he had
wives but he's not like us like he is
not like us he did not mess about he did
not like sister let me let me let me
stop you for a second you said earlier
that she was much older than that but I
just gave you a source and you did not
address it I want you just second just a
second I want you to address the age of
AA because if you have done your
research Shia Islam there are Shia
Scholars who do admit that both sunnis
and Shia agree that AA was a very young
girl when Muhammad married her and
consummating means entering upon her
meaning the
flower that's what I wanted to say God
bless you Habi God logic Paul brother I
will go down because I don't have much
time so do you want me to do you want me
to like explain the the situation or I
have a more detrimental uh position well
I'm more familiar with a more
detrimental position against shiism
because it seemed to me that uh it's
it's regardless about Aisha you don't
hold Aisha as high up as you hold Fatima
and and the other so back to your last
Point who will intercede who will save
you from hell I'm just telling this to
Avery they believe that f
is the Queen of Heaven that she will be
at the gates of hell and she will look
into the eyes of the Shia or people and
say to Allah this is from who or he's
the one that actually from the Shia
group and he won't go to hell so this
this is one of the instances that uh she
last mentioned away from all this what
we need to actually go back to is your
wrong understanding of the morality
between Shia and Christianity are
similar they're absolutely not you are
more similar than Sunni if not more
disgusting but to be honest with you and
I'm not being offensive I'm being true
the the truth is you have exactly the
same things you have analyzing whoever
cusses Muhammad you have not only
analyzed him you actually um I have read
one of your sources says that you take
his wife his kids his money so if if
someone if someone cusses Muhammad you
don't just go after the guy you go after
the family the money the kids are you
serious who's better I think Sunni is
better and then we talk about uh child
marriage and here's what's more
detrimental you believe alif married
this holy woman that's called Fatima
except what you don't know that Fatima
According to some of your sources she
was 9 years old too so it it doesn't
matter if Haisha is uh 20 or 30 or 100
years old you believe the higher person
to you following 9 years old well coming
back to Fatima do you know the age of
Ali when she got married to Fatima it's
irrelevant no it's not irrelevant you
know the whole discussion and compar so
you wait hold on so you agree that she
was 9 years old bro I wasn't alive that
time I'm not sure there's so many things
there's so many sources you know no
there's so many sources let me like let
me just talk I was going to show you the
source yeah let me talk well some show
their sources that Aisha was nine she
asked like they have different resour
sources they have different things but
do you want me to answer for Aisha or do
you want me to answer for fa Z first up
to you up to you so actually the best
thing to do is to tell me who's your Mar
you tell me who's your marja I'll
understand everything without even you
saying anything no no I Paul first of
all you know you are taking different
kind of like people like there's
different kind of I know for a fact
because I lived in Ireland I know for a
fact that there's different kind of
Christians as well with different
they're Roman Catholics they're
Catholics they're Pentecost they're um
in England they are different kind of
Christians with different beliefs and
they contradict each other so if you're
attacking morality sorry excuse me not
on not on morality yeah so if you're
tell if no no I want you to confirm this
none of the Christian none of the
Christian denominations contradict each
other on morality well I don't I don't
believe in Maria system I'm That Kind of
a Shia I don't believe in Maria system
and I've not gone into so deep into that
as well because obviously I've grown
into the West I don't really know what's
going on in the in the East or how
they're taking like Islam to benefit
themselves and to grow and to like be
rich stuff I'm not sure what but could
we understand this a little bit more
then but I can answer you where did
where did the shiism come from did it
come from Ireland or did it come from
you know the East where you know the the
the whole split happened I you don't let
me complete the I'm confused because
you're confusing me I like I cannot pin
you down to anything then that means
whatever answer on AA first do you want
me to answer on I'll meet up sure I'll
mute up okay so first of all about Aisha
there's wiia do not believe that she was
nine wisha believes that she was 18 and
she was a divorce as well and how rasol
Allah married her is that Abu Bakr
basically told Allah that you know this
is this is the Shia Source basically I'm
not sure sunnis are going to come for me
for this they're going to call me things
and come for me but I'm going to go
straight into the fact okay basically
Abu Bakr came tool Allah's door and said
if you do not marry this girl I don't
want her because according to Shia
according to Shia she wasn't a very
righteous woman and that's why rasol
Allah called her the mother of the umah
because when he's gone when he's gone
out of this world like when he's passed
away he didn't want Muslims to see her
other than mother you know other than
anything else other than mother and
don't like like sexualize her or do
things with with her that's why he
called her a mother basically that's
what we think and and we have different
sources on um on this like we she asked
and about her age we do not take
narrations and things from books because
we know that people can write false
things in the books you know we know we
actually go by the history we do certain
things we calculate so there's like few
Shia Scholars who calculated her age
according to her big sister the the the
date of the Hijra and everything and she
was about 18 or 19 years old and about
the Hadith that it's narrated that she
was nine I mean six or seven it's
narrated by her so we do not take her
word because we think that she wasn't
loyal to Prophet Muhammad and Prophet
Muhammad Just Married quite honestly I
don't I don't think this is a fruitful
conversation anyways because you just
told me that you don't believe in any
books so it doesn't matter what you say
anymore I think what we need to do is to
discuss what you believe in which book
you believe in which is the Quran to
treat treat you as a Quran only I think
it's a futile futile conversation at
this point you just affirmed do you
believe no in no books that means that
means everything you're saying is coming
out of your I don't know imagination
perh so so so we can't we can't take we
can't take sorry let me try to finish
this I believe in facts I believe in
speciality okay okay then let's do that
let's do that then instead of
imagination I don't think so for me
Jesus Prophet Muhammad came into this
world just to have us just to like marry
girls and you know do they came this
world this world to spread Humanity
basically they well that's not a
Humanity though let's talk about that
then let's talk about that instead of
telling me uh like you're you're Fork
tonged you're telling me that you don't
believe in books but then you're
bringing something perhaps from your
imagination
and do you then you believe in the Quran
right let's just stay on the Quran yeah
I do believe in the Quran okay then
let's see if the morality of the Quran
matches with the morality of
Christianity I think that's the best way
to do this right right of course yeah go
on okay perfect so let's let's forget
about all this because it doesn't matter
no you don't you don't believe that we
have the same God like the the god that
came no well that's that's sad because
it is honestly it is well that's that's
what we're examining baby we can we can
show you why we're saying that the the
moral the morality of the god of the
Bible is completely different than the
morality of the god of the Quran and
they can't be the same they can't be the
same deity by that standard just can't
you know if God God in the Bible says
this is abhorent I hate this action
right
but the Quran allows this the same
action that's that's not actually that's
a good start
every do you guys online like do you
guys go live every single day like we go
live all the time all the time is it is
it possible if I come live with you
tomorrow absolutely before you leave
because actually every theil on his head
is actually coming back from work and
he' probably like go mad I'm pregnant
and arguing debating he's gonna go back
I promise you Bambi I promise you Bambi
there's something that every hit on the
head
like it can be done in 30 seconds God
have said in the Old Testament that if
if a married woman get divorce and marry
another man and then wants to go back to
her to her old husband that'll be an
abomination in the eyes of the Lord so
this what every was was head on like
this is exactly that something that go
God have detested the god of Abraham but
yet Muhammad comes and say it's
necessary if a if a woman wants to go to
her old husband that she goes and have
intercourse with another man this is in
the Quran and had but that's that's uh
it's in the Quran so that that being
said that's that's FSE that's where
you're getting your information wrong
you can I swear to God that's not what
he said he said if you get divorced from
your current husband and you think you
can reconcile you can you do not have to
marry another man that's so bad like
this is misinformation
I swear to God you can go back to this
which do you read which Quran do you
read so I can I mean you read the Quran
that is imaginary or do you read the
same let's do this let's do this let's
do this so I don't want to do you want
me to bring sources tomorrow I'll bring
yeah B yes please yeah come come back
tomorrow bring you know what what you
what you have bring some sources and
we'll be able to talk about it okay okay
thank you very much it was really nice
talking to all of you you too take care
of yourself God bless you you and the
baby